as forecast as bad words
hello everybody welcome to the
minimalist podcast where we discuss what
it means to live a meaningful life with
less my name is Joshua fields Milburn
and my name is Ryan Nicodemus and
together we are the minimalists we're
recording this on the holiest day of the
year
Cinco de Mayo wouldn't what did you get
me for Cinco de Mayo happy holidays Ryan
poster oh damn it I bought myself a
toaster you know we have a bunch of
questions from our podcast supporters so
I thought we would go ahead and dive
into as many of those as possible Ryan
our first question today is from Lee now
you wanna read that one for us sure when
it comes to organizing your life as far
as time money and ideas for your show do
you use a system to physically see it
like spreadsheets or some type of
hardware platform now I get really
suspicious but begin here's why Ryan I
used to use a lot of different
organizational systems and spreadsheets
and I became very adept at using
Microsoft like that spreadsheet man I
really was your middle name and I in
doing that I had very organized chaos no
well no it wasn't even chaos anymore it
was it was organized tyranny mmm it was
sort of the opposite of chaos but there
is beauty in chaos as well I'm not
advocating for for chaos and but what I
am trying to say here is I get really
suspicious when I think I can solve my
sort of productivity or organizational
problems with adding new things new
systems whatever however there there are
some things that I think are helpful
from time to time when we talk about
budgeting for example you often talk
about the every dollar app and I think
that is more useful especially in fact
here's a more blanket statement I think
will work if you're in a crater debt is
a huge crater to be in right if you're
in a crater where your relationships are
terrible your health sucks or you aren't
contributing to your career in the way
you want if you're in a crater then
maybe there are some apps or systems
that can help you get out of that crater
however if you are not in a
I think some of these things will just
add additional layers of complexity and
that's what we're trying to the opposite
of we're trying to uncomplete employ the
opposite of complex is to simplify and
and really I don't think you can add in
order to simplify I think a lot of
people to use the excuse of well I'll do
that when I find the perfect system to
do that with or I'll do that once I
finish reading this book or whatever it
may be I totally think that some of
those things can actually hold us back
rather than help us but I mean to answer
this question head-on what I love about
how we do the show is we have questions
we look at the questions and yeah we
prepare a little bit but for all intents
and purposes I mean we're kind of
freestyling yeah and in fact what we try
to do is we try to have the simplest
method to produce the highest quality
and so for example if you're watching
this on YouTube I've got some show notes
here that are written literally in Apple
notes sometimes I use Google Docs then
we have this is a Google Doc with all of
your questions on it and then when we do
voicemails Shawn captures those in a
simple mp3 file and then we'll print out
an article but there's nothing very
complex about this yeah we just have an
old-school printer where we print some
stuff out and we we answer some
questions we do prepare but I find it to
be cumbersome to add in a bunch of
different ingredients however you did
meet Jim books and I agree with you that
you shouldn't have to read all the right
books to obtain all the right knowledge
and therefore you are now a master on a
subject you don't even actually want to
achieve mastery that way at all right
the only way you achieve mastery you
don't learn how to become a gardener by
reading gardening books but a gardening
book can give you the knowledge to apply
the sort of tips that will allow you to
get there via the most direct path and
and so those things will give you the
knowledge but not which is not power
knowledge is potential power you still
have to put in the effort absolutely
trudy has a question for us tree writes
in how do you set up a hierarchy between
habits that will propel you forward and
those that will not for example I like
to take classes and learn new skills
some for fun others for career reasons
how long should I continue to stick with
a habit if I
don't see any benefits from it overall a
week a month etc hmm I think we we often
confuse productivity with moving our
hands yeah I also think we think that we
every action we take we feel like we
need to have some kind of passion behind
it or so this great motivation so I
think this is a very apt question
because you know maybe Trudy isn't
feeling the passion with something but
yeah how does she how does she know when
to stop I mean that's oh I think that's
conflating two things in Trudy if that
if that isn't indeed what you're saying
we confuse passion with excitement but
for me I'm not gonna do something now
and by the way I'm learning so much and
we'll talk about it on this episode I'm
sure or maybe even during the maximal
episode by the way all these questions
are from our patreon supporters thank
you so much if you are a patreon
supporter you keep this podcast 100%
advertisement free but back to you Trudy
if if you aren't excited about something
that doesn't mean that you don't have to
be passionate about it but passionate
means that it is a hell yes it's he used
Derek Siver's sort of vernacular in fact
he has let's put a link to that blog
post it's like an essay he wrote called
hell yeah or no I believe is what it's
called but there was a time in my life
especially early on when you're young
when you're first discovering things I
found it was very important for me to
say yes to almost everything when you
and I first started working in Telecom
and I actually started there before you
I was 18 when I started there it was
saying yes to everything let me try this
out let me try this out because that's
the only way you're going to to learn
what you're good at what is appropriate
for your preferences and you're going to
fail a lot but they're not real failures
and I think what we do is we get
confused here when we actually think of
giving up as a bad thing right but man
giving up is one of the almost awesome
things you can do
that's what minimalism is all about
about giving up stuff and then from
there giving up the relationships that
don't serve us anymore
giving up bad habits giving up routines
that no longer service and maybe those
routines even service to us for a period
of time but it's about giving up so that
you're moving forward it's setting the
things down that you no longer want to
carry with you and so the only way
you're going to do that
pick some things up see what it's
appropriate and how long do you do it I
think you know quite often it's it's
you're not ever going to form a passion
overnight you know it's not gonna take a
week but imagine if you really wanted to
write Ryan what's up what's a passion
that you that maybe your 18 year old
self wanted to try out oh I don't know
man
I have no I still play guitar right okay
but playing guitar and you could figure
out really quickly let me just say
guitar if for example courteousness
something you wanted to do here if you
wanted to play guitar instead of trying
it for an hour a week what if you did it
for four hours a day every day for four
months what would that look like you
will you you would no longer not be
proficient at it I guarantee if you did
it for four hours every day for four
months it you you did the really deep
dive you would be you'd be proficient at
it and at that point you would also have
to Drudge through so much drudgery but
that's where the payoff is the payoffs
on the other side of it and by then
you're gonna figure out okay I'm four or
five months into this this is something
I want to keep doing yeah or is this
something I get to set down so I get to
move on to the next thing exactly I mean
that's really the question I think Trudy
should ask is if you're gonna give up
something what are you making room for
so whether you do it for a day or a
month
I don't care treating as long as you're
picking up a boulder that you would
rather pick up than the one you're
already holding I think that's what
really matters and with the guitar
analogy the reason when they came to
mind is because I wanted to be a rock
star
I wouldn't like being a band I wanted to
write music and so I learned how to play
guitar but then as soon as I you know
could play wish you were here stairway
to heaven I'm like yeah I'm good enough
I could like you know I know my bar
chords and I can I can jam along with
someone if they want to jam and I
realized like I really didn't have that
passion to create you know a rock album
for example but I still enjoy playing
guitar every once in a while it's not
something that you know I do every
single day but you know I definitely do
it every single week and yeah it's it's
at a point where I'm happy to passively
have it in my life but yeah I set it
down so I could pick up something else
yeah do you know who Glenn Doyle is I
did a quarantine conversation with her
on patreon she wrote this really
fascinating book called untamed she's a
prolific author has I think three
memoirs out now
and fascinating life where she found out
her husband cheated on her and now she
she left that relationship and and
anyway she talked about addiction and
sometimes we get addicted to certain
things because we think we have a desire
to do something mm-hmm but we have
really we don't question the desire
behind the desire and so what you're
talking about here is really the desire
that you really had was was to be you
have you a rock star or whatever but the
desire behind that may have been
acceptance by other people to be unique
to be significant like what are these
underlying desires and then you can you
can approximate those you don't have to
be a rock star to be accepted you don't
have to be a rock star to play guitar
you don't have to be a rock star to be
loved by other people and so you get to
figure out what is the desire behind the
desire and I think if we start to peel
back those layers of the creative onion
so to speak you start to realize like oh
why do I want this okay but then why do
I want that why do I want the Y what
does Peter say our desires are from the
ones we desire I know I did a bad job
paraphrasing that the mimetic desires
yeah yeah so the Gerard thing is so our
desires just sort of amalgamation of the
desires and beliefs of the people around
them yeah yeah yeah audrey has a
question for us as much as I love the
idea of under calendaring my life that's
a great verb under calor another
calendaring I think there's a taco title
there
it took a pandemic for it to finally
happen any ideas for how to remember
this wonderful place once things get
back to normal in other words how can I
make this my new normal
well right now it is your new normal
right you kind of force the what is it
under calendaring yeah you forced into
it easy for you to say yeah the the I
mean I've learned right I don't know
about you and you just got back from
Montana
a day or so ago right yeah I have
learned so much about myself during this
pandemic during this quarantine during
this virus and what I've learned I've
learned a lot about my preferences and I
haven't unpacked all of them yet but I'm
working through them right now and I'm
also this is gonna be shocking even to
you I think could you know how much of
an introvert I am yeah I'm learning I'm
even far more introverted than I
initially suspected now Ryan this
weekend we came in here me and Shawn and
Jordan we were recording or trying to
touch up some rerecord some videos that
we did and I spent I suppose was a guy's
three and a half four hours together and
and and we were together for four hours
I this is the first time I've been with
anyone in over a month so um I went home
and slept for I had three hour and five
minute Neph immediately like I couldn't
I was so exhausted by being around other
people and it wore me out so bad and I
realized that I've always not always
I've known since I about age 30 29 or 30
that I've been an act or an introvert I
thought it was an extra before that
because I was socially competent but I'm
learning now that in fact we mentioned
Derek Siver's a moment ago I heard him
say this thing Ryan and I think maybe
the opposite will resonate with you
he said there's so many times have been
around people and I've wanted to be
alone I've never been alone and wanted
to be with other people
hmm that's how you know you're
definitely an introvert and I feel the
same exact way about 99% of the time
yeah and there are exceptions where I'm
like I really wish I could but it's not
even I don't miss the going out to
dinner with people I don't miss the like
coffee with other people like I don't
miss that at all and so what I'm
realizing is that it's okay to have
these preferences and it doesn't mean
that I'm right and someone else is wrong
and just like Ryan you were an extreme
extrovert I I imagine the opposite is
true where if you were to spend I don't
know 30 days alone yeah really want to
be around other people oh yeah I don't
think I would
thirty days I mean it's funny the older
I get the more introverted I do get but
thinking about your situation the thing
to is you're getting used to being alone
so you're building that habit so of
course you're gonna come out of this
where you're going to be even more
introverted because you're doing
something that is it's a pattern for you
to easily fall into the more you do that
pattern the more you're gonna get used
to it so when you gotta break it it's
gonna be difficult man so I imagine yeah
when we come out of this you're gonna
have a transition period where you're
gonna you're gonna need more alone time
than what you would have needed before
the quarantine and what that means is
really what Audrey is talking about here
under calendaring right whereas I've
been very good at saying no to a lot of
things but now I'm gonna have to say
that more frequently I feel like in
order to fulfill my own preferences
desires now I'm not confusing those
those preferences the the what's there's
like this old maxim or maybe I made it
up I don't know the the would do would
you do what you do or what is it what
you would do now versus what you want to
do most and and so quite often we want
to do something now watch TV watch porn
you know whatever it is I want to do
this now but what's the thing you want
to do most meaning write the book learn
to play guitar yoga get into shape get
married whatever it might be what is the
thing you want to do most versus the
thing that you want to do now and it's
almost always advantageous to work
toward the thing you want to do most as
opposed to that that ephemeral thing
that is the the plot the ultimate
pleasure seeking did the hedonism of the
now yeah definitely yeah it's
interesting to use during this
quarantine I struggle with like wanting
to be productive a hundred percent of
the time which also isn't healthy like
sitting there and beating myself up for
oh I you know I watched an hour of
Netflix today I mean there is a balance
right I think I think it's I think it's
highly individual yeah definitely so we
what you're saying there is being
productive a hundred percent of the time
actually is is less productive for you
yes
yeah it's well cuz the other thing too
is like even though I am an extrovert
like I still need time to recharge and
like what yesterday so we got home on
Sunday yesterday was Monday and I was
extremely lethargic and I mean it was
from driving in 18-hour day and I mean
cuz we drove straight through from
Montana to Los Angeles 18 hours straight
got a home in 11:30 at night and I slept
really good that night on Sunday night
but on Monday like I just I really
didn't have the energy to do anything
other than like unpack clean up a little
bit straighten up make some phone calls
but like it wasn't it wasn't a day of
like oh I'm gonna I'm gonna write for
four hours today or I'm gonna or I'm
gonna sit here and like do a massive
workout like yeah I didn't even work out
man because I was I was so lethargic so
maybe you know maybe what I'm getting at
is is into your point of it's very
individualized is know your own body and
know yourself and know you know what
what what that percentage of down time
is versus the percentage of productivity
because I fall into the trap of beating
myself up when I'm not a hundred percent
productive so and then when I beat
myself up it makes it even worse I was
talking to I was talking to a friend and
I was explaining them I'm like you know
I really feel like I should be 80
percent productive 20 percent down time
but it's more like 60 40 60 percent
productive forty percent down time and
they were like why are you beating
yourself up for that like maybe that's
what's right for you and I think the
opposite would be true for me where I
where there are many days where I like
to sit down and work for 15 hours and I
can beat myself up the other way like
you should go and watch Netflix or
something where and it's like well okay
maybe if that's what I feel like doing
but it would be silly for me to like say
well I'm gonna stop doing the thing that
is that I want to do most in order to to
take a break from the thing I want to do
most if I don't need that break
necessarily yeah and I think I think
this time right now with with the
quarantine people are finding new new
limits around their interactions around
their creativity around their
consumption and maybe picking up some
bad habits and we're going to talk about
that a little
as well but I think with with the
question like Audrey's question getting
back to normal
mm-hmm Oh core we've already talked
about this we're going to go back right
we're not we're not headed back to
October of 2019 we can only move forward
and you get to decide what that moving
forward looks like you might pull
forward some elements from October 20 19
if you want it might be a complete blank
slate right now yeah there are times and
by the way I think it takes sometimes it
takes crises it took this for me I mean
obviously with my mother dying my
marriage ending when I was 29 years old
these two things happening to me and and
and me starting to let go and
questioning all of the stuff in my life
it took those crises to start asking
some really important questions and it
may take and by the way I'm not unique
to the to this go back to any major
world crises world war one world war two
these we started asking some different
questions as a society and came out of
these situations completely different
from before the these crises happen and
I think the same is certainly going to
be true
it was true for 2008 for many people but
now especially it's going to be true
with this new pandemic and with the
subsequent recession or potentially a
depression that we're going to go into
we're going to be asking some questions
that I think we better ask the right
questions though yeah totally let's move
on to the lightning round Ryan all right
this is where we answer your text
messages usually but I've got more
questions from patrons here but by the
way you can text your questions and
comments 937 202 for six five four those
texts literally go straight to both of
our phones we can't answer every
question via text what we do reply to as
many as we can and if you text us we'll
also add you to our Monday morning a
minimal Maxim so each week we'll send
you a just a little bit a little text a
Monday morning minimal Maxim some simple
living with simple living wisdom each of
Monday during the lightning round Ryan
this is where we both do our best to
answer every question with just a short
shareable lesson
140 character response we don't have
anything prepared so we're gonna come up
with some minimal Maxim's on-the-fly
cool you can find all of our minimal
Maxim's in one place now minimal Maxim's
dot-com Ryan how about we go to Troy's
question toward the bottom of page one
all right cool Troy wants to know how do
I build up the courage to say no to
bosses or coworkers who expect me to do
some work off the clock I'm technically
off but yet if I were to say no or
disregard a request I would be perceived
as lazy I mean the few questions are
gonna ask I - Troy if you were here
right now or if someone else were asking
me this question I would say okay what's
wrong with being lazy first off mmm-hmm
and I think you have to be able to
answer that question for some people
it's that I don't I just don't want to
be perceived as lazy right well okay so
you it's really not laziness that you
have a problem with you have a problem
with being perceived as lazy or the
question then Troy's are you I think
maybe those projecting going on here -
maybe you perceive yourself as lazy and
I'm saying this because now I'm
projecting my own insecurities because
when I was in the corporate world more
often that the reason I worked so hard
and in that that world is because I
didn't want to be perceived as lazy but
really I was perceiving myself as lazy
it's like a MC Escher sketch of
productivity here and and so Ryan I I
think maybe that's the first question we
need to ask but maybe the next thing we
need to talk about is do you need to
find a career long term not immediately
long term then maybe worries less about
the clock you and I don't work on the
client fact when we do this podcast the
only time where we have like a scheduled
time right right
but in same is true with Sean and Jess
and and Jordan anyone else we work with
we're not like did you clock in Sean
right I know you you if you get your if
you get your tasks done and you do them
well you execute them well I don't care
if it takes you 10 hours or hundred
hours to do that thing right and so we
should be more concerned about the
outcome than we are with hours of
productivity yeah yeah I totally agree I
mean it's different when
you've got a boss telling you what to do
and I totally under the question is are
you gonna lose your job and you need
that job and if you do lose a job is it
even worth a job having you know I mean
right now obviously like it's gonna be
hard to go out and find work sure so I'm
sure there are some really jerk bosses
out there who were trying to take
advantage of people yeah I don't know
it's up it's what we were playing this
game it was called would you rather and
this was like weeks ago and one of the
questions that came up it was would you
rather be known as the laziest person in
the world or go through a car wash full
of dicks and I was like herself how big
are these dicks like I would I would be
okay with being known as the laziest
person in the world because the
perceptions of others doesn't matter as
much as the perception of myself right
and that would be my pity answer yeah
and so maybe the question then is whose
perception because if it's my own
perception of myself I wouldn't I'd
rather face the car wash exactly exactly
yeah
yeah so so now I totally agree that Troy
needs to really be clear on is it he's
worried about being perceived as lazy
and if that's if that's the problem
Troy you look in the mirror and you ask
yourself what you perceive of yourself
and as long as you're not gonna lose
your job
who cares if people what people think
about you again like that's depends if
he's gonna lose his job or not right
yeah yeah but who cares what you think
about you you should care about that
right amen and so here's the other
question I'm gonna ask Troy though I'm
gonna just challenge the premise here
maybe because this is the question I
would ask for myself what's wrong with
working off the clock like doesn't if
you enjoy what you're doing wouldn't you
want to do it beyond 5:00 p.m.
sort of thing yeah I mean and so maybe
the question is what if you could find a
career that you're more passionate about
that's more fulfilling that you find
more meaning in then maybe you actually
have less of a problem with working
beyond the the the nine-to-five
or whatever yeah and also Troy when you
are saying no to someone try to express
to them what you're saying yes to
because if off the clock means family
time and you know recharging time or
whatever it is and that's important to
you it's important whoever you're
telling no to what you're telling that
you are explaining to them what you're
saying yes to yeah so here's the pithy
answer for that is whenever you say no
whenever you say yes to something
unimportant you're also saying no to
something more important and so you have
to keep that in mind so if you are
saying like what like Ryan said if
you're saying no to this boss or
whatever I actually tell them what
you're saying yes - I'd rather be doing
this with that time right and if you're
doing a good job adding value to that
company you're not gonna have a problem
communicating that all right before we
get into our added value segment and our
listener tips today it looks like we got
a bunch more surprise questions this
week Ryan we've got a bunch of them from
patreon I'll just read a few of these
here have you succumbed to or been
tempted with falling back to any old
habits during the pandemic do you think
once we as society get back to the new
normal people go back to consumeristic
lifestyles and will it be a worse than
ever and Sarah says I'm unexpectedly
thriving through this pandemic growing
and diving deeper into dark corners with
the space provided to do so my question
is among the struggles so many are
facing how do you allow them space to
feel heard and validated in these times
I think that's interesting dichotomy
dichotomy we're gonna address that Plus
Ryan I think we've got about 40,000 more
questions here and we're going to answer
those on the minimalist private podcast
so if you wanna hear all that listened
to this week's maximal episode on our
private podcast you're currently listen
to our weekly minimal episode but each
week Ryan and I and our guests when we
have guests we record an entirely
different much longer maximal episode on
the minimalist private podcast it's just
two bucks and it's the most honest way
for this podcast to earn an income
because we don't believe in
advertisements you know that we think
advertisements suck so we make money
only if you find value in and support
what we create by the way when you
subscribe to the minimalist private
podcast or receive
personal links so that our maximal
episodes play in your favorite podcast
app it's a totally separate endeavor
these are much longer episodes every
every week and that link that you get
also grant you access to our entire back
catalogue of hundreds of private podcast
episodes some recent private podcast
highlights include Ryan we did this
conversation the 40 days of quarantine
which was over two hours long with dr.
Paul Saladino and Chris Kelly yeah two
of the smartest people I know in two
different perspectives on this pandemic
when should we get back to business
there was some debate some sort of
argumentation but really what happened
here Ryan is we started asking some
questions that I don't think I would ask
in public because the private podcast
gives us this this private space with
trusted people to sort of live out loud
that to mess up out in real time and ask
these questions and the feedback I was
really if I'm being candid Ryan I almost
didn't publish that episode because I
was worried yeah it was well the thing
about the the patron patron episodes
patreon episodes is we can explore
topics that we would not explore with
the masses so yeah I totally understand
we certainly wouldn't publish that to
the masses oh no way yeah I almost
didn't even put out on patreon I'm like
these people understand they get it
right and we provided some different
perspectives and the feedback I got was
wow this was one of the most challenging
episodes you've ever put in front of me
I don't agree with about 60% of it some
people said but it made me ask some
questions that I know I wouldn't have
otherwise asked and that was from both
sides people who were very much stay
inside and and other people who were
like let's open up the economy now and
everyone else in between people were
asking better questions and receiving
better answers as a result also Ryan you
and I've been doing these quarantine
conversations every day over on the
private podcast he's a little short like
12-minute conversations with friends and
friends of the podcast different experts
asking them about how they're coping
with and even thriving during this
pandemic
have you had a favorite one that you've
done so far I like the one you and I did
a lot because I feel like I was
relatable the
open up with because yeah I mean what I
like about what we do whether it's on
the minimal or maximal episodes is we
get to be ourselves and we get to like
share not just oh hey look at all this
amazing life we're living which is great
we get to share that but also we get to
share the the dirty parts doing so I
liked how I got to share a little bit of
the negative stuff on there anything any
of the other ones um man dr. Chris Brown
was interesting um yeah what about you I
did one with Becks in our kitchen oh
yeah
and I really enjoyed that we talked
about a bunch of wild stuff I won't even
say here but and it was just it was
really comfortable and I felt good about
it it took a little while for us to get
into this little groove that one felt
great I did one with Dave Ramsey which
was awesome and did we've done a bunch
of them and I've really enjoyed the
whole process of it just it's there like
much more like phone calls there's no
intro there's no outro it's just hey
Dave how you doing and the thing I
thought about Dave I'm like hey how many
years have you been telling people they
needed to budget now they're just
finally figuring it out yeah and so it
was those have been really enjoyable
we're gonna continue doing that through
through May but then also I'm thinking
about transitioning once we're out of
quarantine - maybe transition these over
to quality conversations where we do one
or two a week where we just call up a
friend for 12 minutes and these are free
to any of our patreon supporters so if
your patreon supporter you get these in
addition to what you're already
supporting us we just as a as a thank
you also Ryan the podcast I did with
Andrew McAfee he worked the the book
more from less we had this conversation
during the maximal episode on patreon it
blew my mind very in he said he's an
environmentalist and he's an MIT
scientist okay
and we started talk about recycling
we've got a question from where the
patrons about recycling and he said
basically everything that you've heard
about recycling is wrong and he's
writing this long essay for Wired he
said hey if you want your plastic to end
up in the ocean just recycle it yeah if
you don't want to end up in the ocean
throw it away and I'm like wait a minute
like I still I'm still not on board with
this
but he gives a really compelling case I
can't wait to read the essay that he
wrote for wire because I feel so strange
putting plastic in the trash bin but I
also don't want it to go into the ocean
so I still need more data but I mean
he's an environmentalist who really
cares about this stuff yeah yeah that
sounds like a great essay man I'm
looking forward to reading it yeah but
in the meantime you could check out that
conversation I had with him also I did
one with Bill Irvine from Wright State
he is like the leading stoic philosopher
and are our regular episode if you
listen to it on the main minimalist
podcast feed was really good the one we
did for the maximal episode was truly
outstanding I mean we just got into this
flow of conversation and stoicism in
fact I think it was when we did this
poll of our of people's favorite
episodes on patreon that was their
favorite of last month I don't know
everything that we did so it's good Bill
Irvine he's this this great stoic
philosopher also professor in Dayton
Ohio of all places you can find all that
at the minimalists comm slash support
Ryan what else you got for us
here are some voicemail comments and
tips from our listeners check them out
hey Josh Ryan my name is Zack Miller
calling from Minneapolis Minnesota
just listen to your podcast I'm not sure
if it was on clothing or travel or
something like that but you've mentioned
clothing and just figured I'd share what
I've learned about my clothing choices
on my journey to becoming a minimalist
my three objectives for any sort of
clothing item that I would own is that
it is functional it is durable and it is
stylistic stylistically versatile a
meaning I can wear it to any or most of
the activities that I would partake in
I generally stick to neutral or earth
tones this way it gets rid of the need
for brands or logos and I can again
pretty much wear it anywhere pop and
color every once in a while with an
outerwear maybe a rain jacket or a
backpack or something like that helps
should identify that it's yours as well
which is a useful function and again
mostly what I wear is geared towards
function what will I use it for
can I use it for many different things
whether it be professional business or
going on a hike
my name is Craig I'm calling from the
Toledo Ohio area and my comment is for
Susan who was wondering about keeping
baby clothes to remind her of when her
newborn came home this I'm sure will
certainly expand into other projects and
papers and artwork as the child
progresses from preschool through
kindergarten up to fourth fifth grade
when most of that artwork is produced we
kept a lot of that stuff all of that
sort of thing went into a big box
because at the time when they're very
young that seems like very invaluable
stuff to keep and ultimately as the
children grew older we started to sort
through it and realize that only certain
pieces meant something or that we're had
something that we really liked and those
were items that got scanned or
photographed and even now my children
are 16 and 19 and as we still find
various things they kind of look at it
and say I don't know how you're keeping
that
and so then we take a photograph of it
and then it goes in the trash so they
don't seem to mind at all and we keep
remembrances of the pieces we like the
best in a digital format and the rest of
it goes away so I guess what I'm saying
is give yourself a little permission
having a baby is a very exciting thing
and as they grow up you will find more
value in certain things than others and
the things that you seem to want to hold
on the most right now may not seem as
important in a few years so give
yourself a little a little time and a
little availability to kind of hold on
to stuff for a little while but not
forever
all right so real quick for right here
right now here's one thing that's going
on in the life of the minimalist
actually I'll give you two things we
rescheduled our tour if you want some of
our tour dates once everything opens
back up we do plan on going back on the
road again we rescheduled all of our
guests as well and that was quite the
endeavor but you can find all of our
tour dates over at the minimalists com a
slash tour if your city isn't on there
go ahead and put your email address in
we'll notify you when we're coming to a
city near you of course never send you
any spam or advertisements or anything
like that but also the thing I want to
talk about is Cove it 19 there's been a
shortage of testing but now antibody
tests are becoming available seems like
that's the best test to take right well
it depends so there's a let's talk about
the difference tween infection tests
which is like the swab which I've had
one of those before as well
versus the antibody test was which is a
blood test and the infection test tests
for active infection so if you had it
right now whether you were symptomatic
or asymptomatic you you would be able to
do a swab as well how uncomfortable was
a very it felt like they were poking at
my brain it was it was very
uncomfortable but it was I mean it
wasn't bad it was just very
uncomfortable and anyway a blood test is
far less uncomfortable or far more
comfortable but a test for the antibody
so if you've ever had kovat 19 you've
been exposed to and you you would have
of course developed the antibody if you
currently have it were to pick up on
antibodies that your body is so yes so
that's what I'm saying so the antibody
tests whether you have kovat or whether
you had kovat it'll get
you a pretty accurate result yeah that
that's certainly my understanding now of
course there are we're not doctors wait
wait a minute doctor Nicodemus by name
only yeah so anyway we bought some for
our team because they're now available
commercially if you're interested the
place we use is a guy I know named Adam
Lam he owns a company called renew life
rx you can find tests I don't get paid
any money we don't get paid any money
for telling you this it's just I've had
a few people ask where they can get
these Co vid tests now and for the
antibodies and it's just renew life rx
dot-com / Co vid but we'll put a link to
that in the show notes as well they do a
bunch of other tests as well I've been
working with them on hormone panels and
things like that but they just got this
test and what you do is you just go in
Beck's and I are going to go next week
and we just you go into a lab core
basically they draw your blood and
within two or three days they say you've
tested negative you tested positive and
there's a part of me that kind of hopes
that like I've I don't think I will I
think I'll come back negative
in fact you said you weren't about a
dollar that you come no III think I
haven't been exposed to well you know
it's interesting is the reason I wanted
a bet a dollar two is because that
conversation we have with Paul Saladino
was it was implying that 40% of people
basically have it and out of me you
Jordan Sean Beck's Moriah I bet you all
of us come back negative well but here's
the thing though I think if one of us
comes back positive is a good chance
most of us come back pause hundred
percent and so if one of us comes back
negative is a good chance all let's come
back negative is yeah yeah now however
that's not necessarily true and what you
know what they're finding out right now
is I was talking to Adam about this he
had a husband and wife couple who one of
them tested positive one tested negative
one has symptoms the other didn't and
they think they're not certain there's
those theories here but they're it has
to do with your DNA there are some
people who are more susceptible to to
the Czar's Co v2 virus than others based
on your genetic makeup this one I
thought we hashed out all the
information possible with Paul Saladino
here's more information yeah so if
you're interested getting a test we'll
put a link to that in the show notes
again we don't get anything for telling
you that
I just have had quite a few people know
it's a great ass it's a great service to
provide it for people who are looking
for it you follow the minimus on
facebook twitter and instagram at the
minimalist if you have a question
comment or minimalism tip for our
podcast email a voice memo to podcast at
the minimalists comm you can comment on
this episode at youtube.com slash the
minimalist and if you want our show
notes in your inbox sign up for our
email list over at the minimalists comm
just enter your email address at the top
we'll send you our show notes every
Tuesday we'll also send you our simple
Sunday emails each week just some
writing about simple living each week no
spam no advertisements no junk ever we
just want to keep you informed of simple
living things for added value this week
all right I think we might have to
switch off of songs in the near future
I've heard a rumor that Apple or iTunes
or Apple podcast I guess it is yeah is
cracking down on copyright things which
is silly because all we try to do is
play a minute of someone's song and well
they're certainly not doing that right
now if the rumor ends up being true I
would hate for our podcast to get pulled
off of Apple podcasts or or anywhere
else that's a lot of editing that we're
gonna have to do so the song you're
listening to right now is is our theme
song which is by Peter Doran and it's
called every little thing so you're it's
already playing in the background right
now I assume Sean and instead for added
value I think well we can still talk
about albums you can still talk about
songs yeah but I just finished a book I
did a pointing conversation with Adrian
Mackenzie who as you know is one of my
favorite authors and he's unbelievable
man he's he's so good he has such a
great story I want to get him on the
podcast next time he's in LA to tell it
because he quit writing and then came
back to it after basically an agent
forced him to and he was right he's
driving Uber's for a while but now he
has this book called the chain that was
just picked up for as a major major
motion-picture nice and it's such a good
Boston mob types don't know it is it's a
it's about kidnapping the thesis of it
is if someone were to kidnap your
kid and the only way you could get your
kid background was it for you to kidnap
another kid would you do it and of
course you would in most parents would
write you you would do the unthinkable
to protect your kid and it's like a
chain letter but with kidnapping and it
is such a good story so it is called the
chain by agent McKenzie we'll put a link
to that in the show notes as well I
encourage you to check it out if you
leave here today with just one message
we hope it's this love people and use
things because the opposite never works
thanks for listen y'all we'll see you
next time
every little thing you think that's me
every little thing you think that you
need every little thing that's just
feeding your greed oh I bet that you'd
be fine without
[Music]